what does Emily Thornbury think of that
government has to make decisions in the
round well of course the government has
to make decisions in the round I mean
what are they doing I was only a few
months ago that they said that they
couldn't possibly pay out any more than
the pay review what he's saying now
today they seem to be saying that
they're going to override the pay review
bodies I mean this is just Economic
Policy by press release doesn't it but
they have to try to get
um our economy under control and they
feel that that is the way to do it this
government well do they or is it they're
just chasing headlines I mean seriously
do they really have a policy at all you
know I was on you know programs like
yours about a year ago when when uh
interest rates were only one percent and
I was saying at that stage you know
there are all of these disputes coming
we need to we need to be sitting down
having discussions we need to sit down
we need to negotiate there will be
compromises we won't get everything we
want workers won't get everything they
want but we should have done it a year
ago and instead what they've done is
that they they recklessly thought that
they could kind of run this as you know
oh these are strikes these are labor
strikes you know let's embarrass the
labor party this isn't a way to run a
country they should have been sorting
these out a long time ago we should
never have ended up in this position I
mean you know we've still got nurses on
strike we've still got doctors on strike
we've got teachers that have been saying
they wanted to talk to the government
for I don't know how long and now we
have the government vacillating between
are we going to pay attention to the pay
review body or aren't we going to pay
attention to the Bay review body I mean
it's not any way to run it labor
supports the independence of the bank of
England yes
so you support interest rates at five
percent we support the bank of England
we know that it has a difficult job to
do but we also think that inter that the
inflation is not just down to what the
bank of England can do it's also having
a proper Economic Policy having some
predictability making sure that the
economy is growing making sure that
wages increase all of these things are
the sort of things that a government
should been doing but we've had 13 years
of the story government that have really
done very little on top of that the you
know the chemical Aussie budget which
has really made things much much more
difficult and this chaos so we say you
know what we would be doing is we would
be much more careful about where we're
going and what we're doing and why we're
doing it but we would be making sure
that we grow the economy because that's
in the end
essence of the problem is that we've had
no growth and nobody's had a wage rise
you know for decades Sandra Bailey doing
a good job the governor of the bank of
England I don't think that it's up to me
as a politic we give the we give the
bank of England Independence we let them
get on with what they're doing
absolutely and so it's not for us to
undermine the decisions that are made by
the bank of England you know they make
decisions on on interest rates but the
government sets the economic policy and
the government can be held accountable
for that and is absolutely right but the
bank of England has to respond to the
economic conditions that are the
responsibility of the government is he
doing a good job
right he's
yeah I'm sure he's doing a good job I
mean that's not really the issue the
issue is fundamentally the economic
weather which is created by the
government
uh mortgages we talked about as a result
of the interest rate being at five
percent your party analysis has found
that new mortgages will now cost a
typical household 2 000 pounds more per
year in France at a thousand pounds more
than in Ireland and Belgium yes bye
well there's a number of reasons I mean
as many of the things that I was talking
about before which is that we are in a
much worse position economically than
those than those countries all of these
countries have had the pandemic all of
these countries have had the problems
with Ukraine but we have had structural
and fundamental problems within this
country that haven't been addressed and
that's been as I say going on for more
than a decade now so we need to have a
change you need to have a different
approach to to Economic Policy one that
has the long-term in view so we need to
be making sure that we're investing we
need to be we need to be making sure
that we need to change the planning
policy we need to make sure that we have
some policies that actually will grow
the economy only out of growing the
economy or we have the money to invest
in public services and only if we have
decent Public Services can we support
our country only if we have a proper
infrastructure can you make sure that we
grow our economy but you guys get
yourself tied in knots as well don't you
I'm thinking about green policies I'm
thinking about what Rachel Reeve was
saying I think it was 28 billion pounds
a year that you're going to spend and
now you're saying you know it's not
going to be that it's going to be up to
28 billion over a period of time so on
day one we won't be spending 28 billion
that's all we're saying we're saying
that we're going to build up tonight
obviously she said you were well yeah
but you know but actually what we need
to do well because it works better if we
build up to it so why not say that in
the first place well look this is what
we're saying okay so we build up to it
we build up to 28 billion I mean there
are two reasons why one is that we won't
overnight be able to find the
gigafactory as we won't be able to
double the onshore wind we won't be able
to double the offshore window
and the other reason is is that because
of the the costs of borrowing are so
high that we need to look again at that
so it's both those things together that
we have tweaked the policy but the
fundamental principle is this is that
the only way to grow our economy is to
change the way our economy runs and that
is about bringing in green energy which
means jobs which means infrastructure
which means investment you know all of
which means security which means not
answering to Putin for for the prices of
our bills you brought that up I mean you
were previously Shadow foreign secretary
um
how would you be dealing with the
situation that's going on in Russia at
the moment if you were in power
I don't think there's very much that we
in Britain can do about the situation at
the moment apart from prepare ourselves
you know for for well we have to prepare
ourselves for I think I suspect
um quite a long period of of instability
within within Russia but probably more
importantly actually in our immediate
interests is what the effect is going to
be in Ukraine and certainly we hope that
this world that this in that this
instability will undermine Russian
confidence in Ukraine will give the
ukrainians an opportunity at this stage
and whilst the Russians are distracted
by this and hopefully it will mean an
end to the war soon and the ukrainians
being able to win back their territory
so that we can have the peace that we
need
doesn't the West need to be careful what
it wishes for
um displacing Putin could result in the
leader potentially the Wagner group or
another who is even more of a threat to
the west but I also think we we
shouldn't just treat the Russian people
as just being bystanders in this I mean
you remember in I think it was uh the
lot when when there was a there was a
there was a big Uprising I remember in
uh in Russia I think it was in 1991 and
uh and the Russian people went onto the
streets and just said actually you know
don't forget us you know the the Russian
military can't be the ones who make all
the decisions on this we want to have a
say in our future too and they won you
know so did they win yeah yeah yeah
there was a change over there was yeah I
know but in the short term the the the
the there was a Handover which the which
the Russian military were trying to stop
but it did happen so we did have the
change in Gorbachev so that was
important the Russian people had a say
in it so
it isn't just about the ministry it
isn't just about Putin there is a
population there too who I hope will
have a say
just before I let you go there's going
to be a reshuffle we're told um next
month
um
um what job do you fantasy
or reshuffle in the shadow cabinets oh